hey good humans Jason here and we've got
a big announcement today we're dropping
another collection of human good called
service-level take a look this whole
theme is about judgments and how we come
to these judgments often on a surface
level make sure you check out human good
Olay calm and stick around the end
because we have a special promo hood for
you for now enjoy the episode personally
like I'm in refer to myself I'm gonna
say autistic person but you can say
either/or and I won't give a crap
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Jay I'm 19 I was diagnosed
late with autism you know there's no way
to look autistic it's just a whole
spectrum of people I'm Josiah I'm 18 at
first I was really unsure about it
because it sounded like it was bad but I
started to realize that autism is more
like me than it is a disease my name is
Shayna crashing I'm 23
autism is more prevalent than people
think and just if we could make the
world more aware and acceptable towards
it it'll just be a lot easier for
everybody I am Christopher Carroll I am
38 years old I like to act was that not
related to autism
I'm yoni I'm 19 and I am an artist at
all times I really am proud to have
autism it makes me see the world
differently and that's totally awesome
my name is Bella I'm 22 years old in
high school I couldn't really talk so I
was like nonverbal I've just become more
confident in myself and being able to
talk to other people
special benefit three-two-one
I do find it to be somewhat of a bad
label this person is special as in two
different to function I guess it's like
when I I perform in the performances
I've been in people begin to whisper in
the audience whisper among themselves
was that person person special or not
and that that seems a little harsh to me
especially could be used as something
good
but it can also be used as you know
something like Oh like why aren't you
hanging out with them oh because they're
special like you know like they're the
other they're less than and it's we're
not less than we're different if you
like I can make neurotypical people feel
better like it's like the right word to
say and like it just sounds nicer to
them but in reality I think it's just
more offensive if you're like using it
with it but that kind of tone and
inflection what I think about special in
the terms of autism I think about
special Edie and for me it's like why is
it special to have some extra
accommodations or to learn a different
way like it's not special that it's
extra supported I agree allow the word
special can mean pretty much anything
it's just the way that people take it
and I don't think that's fair
it's hard for me to make friends because
yeah I didn't really start making
friends until I started college cuz I
wasn't like in a lot of activities and
stuff I just always wanted to be by
myself and I always found it hard to
talk to people um for the longest time
especially when I was in middle school I
had a bit of a hard time making friends
and so I was basically on my own for a
while but until I made it until I made
it I totally went to UM junior high I
went to a on private school there home
to our goal was to basically like make a
community that are just trying to find
friends and stuff like that
so that's why I'm on this somewhat
disagreed because it's like I have
plenty of friends now but in the long
run when it came down to middle school I
had a really rough time I honestly don't
have trouble making friends I talked to
everyone I meet and everyone I meet I
kind of make friends with I don't know
it just comes naturally to me I just say
hey let's be friends and they're like
yeah and it happens when you first meet
somebody I'm good at the initial like
talking and friend thing but it's when
like the long-term and you know it just
gets too complicated and then like also
I just find like I don't like a lot of
people and so like of course not a lot
of people are gonna like me so it's just
so it's just like some would agree well
I I guess for me it's just I also have
social anxiety so it's never been easy
for me to make friends but I sometimes I
just feel better being by myself
and doing my own thing and when you go
out and you meet people you have to
really push yourself to you know to know
what to say and to know what not to do
and you don't stim and stuff like that
so it's just harder to go out and have
that whole mental energy put towards
that when you can just be yourself by
yourself but I do have some friends so
that's why I'm here not there I have a
similar problem I was younger I had
so phobia and I spent a lot of childhood
just living or playing inside my own
head which didn't exactly seem to help
me with people's skills yeah it can
trigger things your can like trigger
meltdown like you don't want to have to
deal with sensory issues period period I
was just saying I feel yeah well for
years years I was wondering like why is
the music in the car where no one else
is saying it's loud why is it hurting me
why he's like why can't I make friends
easily why am I not picking up on
sarcasm I feel like it really did help
me understand myself because I stopped
feeling so bad my body and brain
sometimes work against each other when I
first read the what are they calling
it's not symptoms criteria what criteria
yeah the criteria for autism it was like
mind-blowing because it was like reading
something I didn't even know existed and
could be put into words like I said I
thought everybody was just dealing with
it and hiding it better and I've turned
to so much more self-love since I found
out about my diagnosis just two years
ago it's just been like probably the
most freeing thing for me I actually
used to have meltdowns like daily I
would just get so angry and nobody knew
why yeah and I didn't know why I would
just pop it on and I realized that after
I got diagnosed of autism everybody
around you notice how less angry and how
many like how less my meltdowns were
because you start to know how to prevent
them because you start to know what's
making you meltdown well I think I have
to say I somewhat disagree because I've
not actually been diagnosed
no one's tested me for autism so what do
we go by just simply what a doctor
happens to say on any given day or what
made you want to come today
a few doctors have said I have autism
although at least twice as many doctors
I've known to have said I do not what do
you what do you believe now I I believe
I do have autism somewhere but I can't
say I agree with the diagnosis because I
don't actually have a diagnosis are you
planing to get one in the future I don't
know anyone who'll give me one that's a
big issue actually they're crazy
expensive and crazy hard to get I guess
like a whole ordeal
I got what for my psychiatrist cuz I was
already under his care yeah it really
does help me especially to find a
different route with education like I
had a huge problem with mathematics and
stuff like that and now after I got
diagnosed and I'm going to the school
that helps typically with autism it's
like now I'm doing statistics it does
really help it really helps me to
understand what how my brain works and
how I can get help and because I know
that my brain works differently I see
the world in a more creative aspects
thinking outside of the box and I'm over
here like I'm outside of the like I'm
that's out of the you can't even find
the ball I'm in the galaxy excuse me the
shapes are around me and I'm outside of
all of them
I get pity for a lot of things because I
don't have only autism I have multiple
mental illnesses and medical conditions
- and everyone when I like tell them all
then they're like how can you be happy
your life sounds difficult I'm like it's
not that like it's just what I know it's
it doesn't have to be the end of my
world and I don't like getting pity for
the things I have because just because
I'm disabled doesn't mean my life
necessarily sucks because of that yeah I
only said someone disagree because I
grew up like really obsessively masking
I don't think people pity me I think the
opposite I think people have very high
expectations of me because I can kind of
mask and present that I think that most
people forget I'm autistic and don't
treat me with the some of the help I
need and have a lot less patience for it
and so I don't know how much I'm pity
more the time I'm not believed I've even
had like therapists try to like convince
me I'm not I have to like teach them
about it and then they say I'm not so
it's very frustrating I can't change the
way I am so instead of pity I want
people to try to understand and accept
it's also just like don't pity me like
be with me like like be with me in the
moment like don't feel bad for me like
like as if you can't do anything like
treat me like I am like I am just a
normal person so like growing up people
used to like baby me and now like I look
at being 22 I look back and it's like
they just should have probably treated
me like a normal child just that can be
a hindrance in itself people babying you
that exactly they're at it not you don't
it makes me feel like I can't be in my
own person yeah I used to have that
problem with a lot of people like they
would be like oh it's okay we're we're
all little autistic or something like
that and it's like no there
I hate back on it so much and I get yeah
we're not all autistic just because you
have like you relate to like a couple
things on the trait doesn't mean that
you're autistic necessarily have to have
more than just three things you know
yeah then you're just being a person
just relate to a few it's like you're
human too
I strongly disagree because if I didn't
have autism I won't be the same exact
person part of my identity but I really
be the same person if I didn't have
autism but I think I have to stick with
just somewhat because I haven't actually
been diagnosed with autism so another
thing is that the issues in the
struggles that like I have with being
somebody with autism is like that I
encounter day to day mostly have to do
with the fact that I'm living in a
neurotypical world not that I have
autism if that makes sense so it's I
would much rather live in a world that's
more aware of autism and/or a less
neurotypical heavy world that would be
what I would rather change not changing
myself if that makes sense that's why
before diagnosis first language like
autistic person then people with autism
because personally it's like my autism
makes up me it's not just like a part of
me like I my diabetes is a part of me my
pancreas not working doesn't affect my
the way I act the way I am but my autism
it affects the way I see the world the
way I process the way I feel things the
way I go about things and socialize and
even though I don't like everything
about myself I don't think that being
not autistic would make me love myself
suddenly I think it's just about the
fact that I just need to work on
accepting myself more in general so I
feel like I'd rather have my autism
because it made me mean yeah I also I
would say personally like I'm a person
with autism but I also don't care really
how people use it I remember when they
started saying like autistic person
versus person with autism I was like oh
okay
I don't care yeah like I don't you call
me either but if I had to pick
personally like if I'm gonna refer to
myself I'm gonna say autistic person but
you can say either/or and I won't give a
crap because
I see it as like a neurotypical
community being like oh we just didn't
mean to me as nice as we possibly can
notices I don't know I feel like I've
never heard an autistic person freak out
about it really I always hear
neurotypical people freaking out about
it
well like I kind of agree because some
people have the same exact things that I
go through but then also somewhat
disagree because people there's like
higher functioning and lower functioning
so it's kind of hard to connect to
people that are like I don't know what
to say that yeah I got that yeah I got
because they're so different I guess it
could be I guess harder to you know
connect and in some degree but we may
not all go through the same exact things
but as a label like autism I think we
can all like connect to that and that's
how I feel like with the label with that
label I feel like there's a good sense
of community there I do agree it's like
although we have different stories about
how of you know of how of autism I
believe that we where we can relate to
each other and still like um have
different perspectives yeah exactly
because it's like I feel like especially
right now it's like we spread apart
because you know we're scared to say
that we're autistic but I believe that
um we need to start to group together
and start to educate people and you know
I've noticed the rising communities
online yeah narrow diversity yeah when I
when I first found out it was like great
to like deep dive into the internet and
get all these autistic perspectives and
I and I connected with that online but
then when I found when I went in real
life and I started to meet people or
started to talk to people more I I felt
just kind of isolated again and I felt
kind of like that same thing I think
it's just the same thing if I'm in a
group of neurotypical people from a
grouping autistic people I'm just gonna
still kind of feel alienated and so I
just kind of stopped trying after it
helps when you don't have to explain
yourself to others then you can just
relax and hang out without any judgement
Thank You Jo
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey guys thanks again for sticking
around if you're still here make sure
you go to human get alikom to check out
the amazing new surface-level collection
and for you amazing good humans we
actually have a special discount code
it's only available for 48 hours from
the drop of this video so if you're
watching right now
go to the website human go telecom
alright we love you guys we'll see you
next time
[Music]